whether you're working or stay at home
as a parent the guilt is something we
have all experienced board certified
psychiatrist dr sue varma joins us right
now to discuss the psychology behind it
and some tips on how you can ease that
guilt good morning how you doing good
morning great okay so parent guilt is
something a lot of us can identify with
where does it come from
you know it comes from this strong bond
and attachment that we have with our
children it comes out of love it comes
out of a need to protect them from a
biological point of view from an
evolutionary point of view it's
protective right where's our kid are we
feeding them are they hungry what do
they need from us but the downside is
that sometimes it can be irrational it
can be feeling guilt over things that we
have no control over that we have no
responsibility over
but it's a need for certainty and
wanting to make sure that our kid is
okay and that we can control the outcome
and sometimes we don't always have
control the expectation on parents
particularly moms has changed so so
women work much more than they did in
the 1960s and yet they also according to
pew spend more time doing child care so
you're doing both things and so many
hours in the day absolutely and it's
often coming at the expense of our
sanity our mental health our friendships
um and our hobbies which also have
decreased since the 1960s you know i can
remember when favorite daughter kirby
took her first steps i was working i was
anchoring the new news
and
a co-worker said to me who shall remain
nameless shaniqua
you must feel really bad that you
weren't there and i said why would i
feel bad it's noon i'll get home at six
so when i see it it will be
my
my it will be me seeing her first steps
and i just refused to beat myself up
about that her dad had recorded it so i
got to see it on video but sometimes we
are just made to feel guilty by other
women which i just think is an awful
thing to do absolutely and i'm so glad
gail that you didn't buy into that um
you know because she
and i said to her look she's not going
to be running a marathon by the time i
get home right exactly we'll still be
toddling around i just thought that was
such a crappy thing to do absolutely you
know a lot of women end up what happens
is you didn't but a lot of women end up
internalizing shame yes and shame is
profoundly
corrosive and dangerous to our mental
health it can lead to anxiety to
depression and women have more
shamefulness more anxiety proneness than
men do so there are difference between
shame and guilt absolutely so guilt
moves towards reparation it says did i
do something wrong all right well i can
fix it and it's about behavioral change
because we can change behavior but shame
is about character assassination it says
like i'm a horrible person you can't
just change who you are overnight as a
person guilt moves us towards pro-social
behavior and gets us closer to people
but shame alienates us and isolates us
do men and women feel it differently
absolutely you know i think that often
if
men and this is a stereotype but if men
feel guilt it's about something
circumscribed in the environment that
actually happened and it's concrete like
in the moment in the moment whereas and
they can point to a specific problem i
didn't show up to this i feel guilty
whereas for women i feel like the guilt
is often pervasive it's like you're
damned if you do damned if you don't you
went to the game but you went five
minutes late oh my god you went to the
game but you didn't bring the cookies
and the snacks for everybody else they
never give themselves a break they're
such an unrealistic high standard it's a
moving target a chasing a moving target
that you will never be able to live up
to that description is spot on in my
relationship by the way
so how do we ease that guilt
self-compassion um and self-compassion
is not just this fluffy thing that we
talk about but it is actually
science-based and there are three
components to it being kind to yourself
and kindness looks like affirmations i'm
doing a good job i may not be the best
mom but you know what i'm good enough
and good enough they say you know
perfection is enemy of the good kindness
also looks like taking breaks taking
care of your mental health scheduling
time for therapy scheduling time for
girl friendships for friendships being
apart getting connected back to who you
were
mindful observation is the second part
don't get over identified with your
feelings say oh there's the mom guilt
again you know what but i'm a good
person i'll be there like you said those
statements like i'll see it i'll see it
when i get home and the third thing is
common humanity is this idea that we are
part of something greater we're
something bigger than ourselves and
we're not alone in what we're feeling
recognize that you're not alone a lot of
people feel like this no one is perfect
and it takes a little bit of the edge
off of yourself and you can practice
this every day such good advice i feel
so many parents feel when they're at
work they feel like they should be at
home when they're at home they feel like
they should be doing work yeah you never
feel like you're in the right place at
the right time and what you're saying is
great advice for getting really out of
that cycle yes and tony one more thing
you know they say like women are
expected to parent like they don't work
and work like they don't parent and
that's the hardest thing that's exactly
true meanwhile dad's getting pat's on
the back
wiping one runny nose in the supermarket
way to go yeah way to go and babysitting
yeah baby
babysitting which you said about
yourself your dad don't ever use the
word babysitting that's for sure do not
because that's bs do not
babysitting yes dr sue varma thank you
always good to have you here come